you
this was a check that got to be a
at all we called a shed bird it's a
little nest bolt was outside the shed
that be used to photograph marine
creatures he was cute we'd say hello and
all of that one day it was getting
closer to fledging and it looked kind of
listless I squirted him down a little
bit of water to cool him off but the
next day he had died the refuge managers
Cynthia Vanderlip did a necropsy on the
bird cause of death I would seem to be
plastic there's so much plastic floating
in the water and the parents mistake it
for food so here we have a toy
bottle cap the chicks take all of what
their parents have to regurgitate
including plastic a small amount of
chicken Kofa but when it becomes as much
as shed bird head it's overwhelming I
took everything that was in shed Birds
stomach and arranged it I wanted to see
every single last thing
it's not really clear what the solution
is do we as a culture need to rethink
our use of plastics I think we do and
certainly how we dispose of them
you